the headlines on Al Jazeera this hour at
least 296 people have been killed after
an earthquake struck the center of
Morocco the magnitude 6.8 Tremor hit
late on Friday evening rescue operations
are underway but large numbers of people
are believed to be trapped under the
rubble the Quake sappy Center was high
in the Atlas Mountains roughly 70
kilometers Southwest of the city of
Marrakesh but sharks were also felt in
the coastal cities of Robert Casablanca
and desawira
everyone here felt the Tremors and it
sent us all into a panic fortunately
there haven't been any injuries among us
we could hear the Clutter of our
equipment crashing to the ground
prompting us to hastily flee
we're all filled with fear completely
caught off guard by the sudden Tremors
the signs were there doors and windows
shaking violently thankfully we're
relieved that the Quake wasn't as
powerful as it could have been
we were just about to sit down for
dinner when the earthquakes struck we
then left the food behind but we were
very relieved that the apartment
building didn't collapse thank goodness
for that
or India's prime minister Narendra Modi
opened the